o saber de los pánicos de los pánicos
genera las nuevas tecnologías yo soy
periodista y siempre me gustó mucho la
historia también por mi carrera y cuando
uno ve la relación que tienen las nuevas
tecnologías a través de los tiempos y
los miedos que éstos provocan uno se da
cuenta de cómo dice led zeppelin no la
canción siempre es la misma
la cosa se repite fíjense por ejemplo
que estamos viendo ahí eso que estamos
viendo es una cosa que se llama ostra
acá cuando los griegos les cabía un
jarrón guardaban los pedacitos por
darnos pedacitos porque en esos
pedacitos podían escribir cosas yo se
acuerdan en el secundario cuando estaba
lo de los metecos y los ilotas cuando
había que votar que habían había que
echarlo de la polis la gente iba con sus
cachitos de ostra acá y votaba inicia
que se vaya y los pimientos y una
bandeja ella esté condenaban al
ostracismo la dice la palabra abstracta
si ustedes lo mira bien es un pedacito
si quieren es como un proto post-it ok o
un o el primer twitter de la historia
porque no está más que 140 caracteres
ahí adentro misteriosa de varias veces
más las redes sociales siempre fueron
como lo estamos viendo ahí hay un grupo
de gente que tiene
otro grupo de gente que otra idea y un
conector en el medio y fíjense por
ejemplo en el muro segura que en pompeya
un volcán bueno eso permitió que quedara
todo como congelado y pudimos ver que la
gente escribía grafitis en los muros
escribía cosas como por ejemplo gane a
los dados 8 mil 522 de nadie y no seria
buen juego el 19 de abril y sepan el
nombre con el que estoy cenando es un
bárbaro o a ti me tus me dejó embarazada
o sea las mismas cosas que uno puede
llegar a ver en el muro de facebook ok
había cosas interesantes lo de los
domingos una vez la proliferación de
parrillas cuantas parrillas puede haber
un mundo men es exactamente lo mismo
[Aplausos]
ustedes aplaudan que el tiempo corre
fíjese esto también acá si se lo decía
el 24 de marzo te envía una copia de la
carta de balbos para mí y de césar para
él porque porque las cartas en ese
momento eran documentos semi públicos
entonces si yo si hicieron tenía como un
in june auto entonces cuando vi una
carta copada me decía que me hace una
copia y las cartas son copiadas y se
transmitían básicamente igual que con
uno tiene una red peer to peer
cuando hace no nosotros pero viene la
gente que baja series y baja películas
bueno es lo mismo se da a casa así se
transmitían información y poca de
cicerón y miren esta mujer lo que tiene
en la mano
no es no es un no es un galaxy eso
podría explicar por ejemplo que pasó en
pompeya que había un montón de son su
kalex y guardado y se reventaron todos
al mismo tiempo y voló todo al demonio
pero no fue eso sino que tiene es lo que
tiene esa señora en la mano que tiene el
mismo formato sea lo que llama tablas
era está la tabla será está era si
quieren como un ipad romano ok en una
tabla considera entonces pongamos eso
servía para mandar mensajes no sé
supongamos que yo te quería mandar un
mensaje de ariño entonces escribía en
latín con un palito darío extra que
tampoco en latín se puede decir el
apellido
darío te espero para comer un asado
y eso se mandaba con un esclavo
es cuando el dar yo lo veía como en
ácida lobo roja con la mano y después me
decía sigue ramiro llevó a la duma de
fred um y volvía al esclavo ahora esos
esclavos se llamaban los tabular y y
cuanto más tabulares tenía que
significaba qué es lo que tenía y
similar a hoy más ancho de banda porque
podía mandar más mensajes adentro de
roma era muy práctico eso
y mira este señor también estos de
pompeya este esencial que es un panadero
yo master entero y fíjense lo que tiene
eso es un fresco estaba en su panadería
y fíjense que está con un rollito ok y
está con una toga y la señora también
tiene un palito y una tabla se trata y
por qué tenía eso porque tener una toga
71 negro lo que decía es soy romano soy
ciudadano que era muy importante y
también decía mi mujer escribe y lee
también es básicamente que era estamos
viendo las primeras el fin de la
historia
si estoy en red acá en el himalaya por
la gente siempre tuvo necesidad de
contar sus cosas y miren esto que es de
la biblia con esta carta que ha sido
leída entre vosotros hacer que también
se lea en la iglesia de la licencia así
que la de la hora de dice a la ley
también vosotros ya eso leerlos milagro
hizo que pasaba
el fundador de católica fue san pedro
pero era como el cio pero el número dos
en sido wow el gerente de marketing era
san pablo que era muy inteligente y
cuando uno tiene que armar una religión
tenía que ponerse todos de acuerdo en
cuáles serán los lugares y cuáles eran
las reglas que iba a tener ustedes creo
que dice san pablo yo te voy a hacer una
pregunta si ustedes respondo pero vos
manda de la respuesta al otro y al otro
y al otro y al otro así todos estábamos
de acuerdo en un dogma y cuando los
católicos organizan los domingos vieron
que dicen carta de los dice en cesano
que estamos viendo estamos viendo el
mail con guardar yo fue rodeado más
grande de la historia son 2000 años de
un mail de una carta que se va enviando
una y una y otra vez
y seguimos con la seguimos con las
seguimos con las con las católicas h con
las 95 tesis del útero el útero se había
enojado para lo que llamaba indulgencias
plenarias que era que vos podías comprar
a crédito perdones tus pecados o no si
nos vamos a las vegas' de fin de semana
que compremos indulgencia pruebas a
cualquiera entonces esto lutero le
parecía malísimo está totalmente en
contra entonces escribió en un lugar y
más wittenberg en una iglesia de
sustitutos y puso las 95 razones por la
que estaba en contra sino tiro tuve que
hacer eso hoy quería podría ser por
ejemplo un whatsapp unidad se pediría la
iglesia católica está vendiendo
indulgencias y eso me pone muy mal por
ejemplo
podría ser algo así
onda bastida 95 razones por la crisis y
locuras de amigos podría ser también así
y fíjense ahora cuando vieron los medios
electrónicos por pinares se guardan como
era antes un grupo comunicaba a otro
grupo pero por primera vez una persona
le podía decir lo mismo a muchas
personas a la vez eso no había pasado
nunca en la historia y tiene un lado
bueno totalmente un lado malo acuérdense
miren esto que es hans georg dance with
en fürher knicks el folk enfrentar que
no importa que díaz en alemán suena
horrible es toda alemania escucha el
figure concepto del pueblo era que
regalaban eso y solamente puedes captar
las acciones alemanas primera idea
entonces somos hijos de una anomalía
siempre hubo redes sociales por un
tiempo muy chiquitito entre 1915 hasta
ahora hasta hace unos años hubo la
posibilidad de algo piramidal pero somos
un momento loco de la historia ahora
volvió a la normalidad
miren esta frase la erupción digital
solo producirá el olvido en las almas en
la que la conozcan haciendo la expresión
la memoria confiados en este auxilio
extraño abandonarán a caracteres
materiales de cuidado de conservar los
recuerdos cuyo rastro ha perdido su
espíritu la erupción digital
quién lo dijo real dijo de la escritura
está en el filtro de platón esto lo
decía teóricamente sócrates en contra de
la escritura lo mismo luz en digital
cambiemos ahora los ebooks van a dejar
sin trabajo las imprentas y no es lo
mismo un kindle que un libro de papel
en realidad es la imprenta bases de
trabajo los monjes en ahora mismo un
libro impreso de un códice copiado eso
lo dijo johan este extremos en el siglo
15 otra más
los niños han desarrollado el hábito de
dio su atención que la identifican de
preparación de sus deberes y las
llamativas de versión de la playstation
por la noche se quedan despiertos
desvelados o se despiertan gritando por
un sueño enterrador directo resultado de
las pesadillas provocadas por los
violentos videogames tranquilamente eso
lo podemos leer hoy pero en realidad es
de mil 936 esencia de la radio la gente
escuchaba los relatos y los nenes
dormían siempre cuando hay una
innovación algo a alguien no le gusta
siempre alguien se queja por algún lado
siempre un callo que duele de algún de
alguna persona
de algún grupo siempre alguien dice no
esto no me gusta
[Aplausos]
desde la idea 12 que la innovación
siempre llega por donde menos en la
espera de esta señora se mantiene
papeles no antropóloga de intel y lo que
dice es que toda tecnología para que
provoque un cambio y un miedo en la
gente tiene que cumplir tres
características tiene que afectar el
tiempo tiene que afectar la relación que
nosotros con el tiempo la relación de
nosotros con la distancia y la relación
de nosotros entre nosotros mismos y
fíjense por ejemplo siempre decían que
las primeras víctimas teóricas son las
mujeres y los niños esto es de julio del
95 ese saber por los niños terrible uno
dice bueno ya está no no está esto es de
agosto del 2006 que dice que los niños
van a ser violados por los usuarios de
pokemon go ok
sea en cuenta que es la misma fórmula
que se repite una y otra vez y significa
que por ejemplo la ley luz eléctrica
genera impacto en el tiempo si de golpe
dominamos la noche con las distancias sí
porque ya no había más oscuridad o sea
podías ver lo que pasaba por allá
incluso en razones personales el
telégrafo decían que iba
romper el tejido social porque ya la
gente nos sigue a visitar si yo le podía
mandar utility diría que estoy
comandadas que hacer para que iba a ver
yo la gente estoy va a ser de acabose y
miremos la birome un invento argentino
baby no me afecta entre relación el
tiempo asistencias no por eso nunca van
a escuchar que digan hay tipos que los
chicos desde que usen la birome ya son
terrible eso nunca nunca lo van a
escuchar si de cualquier tecnología
moraleja
siempre que aparece algo nuevo nos causa
alguna resistencia pero los días no
seres humanos siempre buscamos lo mismo
buscamos que nos quieran buscamos una
relación con familia buscamos trascender
de alguna forma nos da irá el cambio o
nos da pereza aceptar algo nuevo pero
tomemos cosas como la que dijo el
maravilloso este kato antes y tomamos
las virtudes hagamos que elijamos aunque
nos cuesta a veces un poco la luz
eléctrica aunque nos dé un poco de miedo
porque siempre es mejor te quedarás en
un rincón o una velita y tenerle miedo a
la oscuridad ya los monstruos que uno
podría imaginar por ahí muchas gracias